That's rough, man. Dude, he's sick of my
autism. Wife left and took the kids. Way
more time for Warhammer and YouTube, am
I right, man? Way more time for
Warhammer and YouTube now. This guy says
way too much.
>> does I need the state to take this guy's
YouTube channel away. I need him to be
legally stopped from talking online. By
the way, the wife took the kids. I can
hang out on Discord all day. [laughter]
Let's go. The most divorced conversation
of all time, they're calling it. Today,
I have possible peak content to share,
okay, guys? Possible peak content to
share. Connor, Counter-Points, long-time
friend of the stream, has done a very
interesting
little announcement today. Now,
recently, obviously, we found out that
one of our chatters was cocked by Moral
and subsequently splitting up with his
wife, commentary chatter Rena B. Now,
I'm not sure that's quite what's
happening here, guys, but Connor is,
certainly, getting divorced. Um so,
we're going to take a look at this,
guys. Connor decided today to announce
that his wife had served him with
divorce papers. I'm not quite sure why
he's decided to do that, uh but from the
brief bit of this I saw, it was quite
amusing. Now, I'm not just delighting in
his divorce, okay? I Like I said, I do
feel a little bit bad. Not bad enough to
stop me making fun of it, but a little
bit bad, cuz it is like,
it's I'm sure it I'm sure it sucks. I'm
sure he's got kids. If I I'm sure it
sucks, you know. But also, it is just
amusing, cuz Connor is like this trad,
you know, tells everyone you should live
this way a guy. It's just always, you
know, there is a little bit It is a
little bit amusing when stuff like that
doesn't work out for these people. It It
does, you know, put a little bit of a
smile on my face. And And just the way
he talks about it is going to be quite
amusing, guys, okay? Just Just the way
he talks about it is going to quite
amusing. So let's let's see. Let's have
a look. Depends on the bomb. I want to
know your secrets. Hold on. Let's see
what the answers comes. With a personal
bombshell. Going to be This is while
he's watching Kilo's sound video it
seems guys. That's when he decides to
talk about this. Tough. Okay. Can I Can
I hit you all with a bombshell? Can I
Can I I'm going to ask Christian
Valera's. Can I hit you all with a
personal bombshell?
Should I hit you all with a personal
bombshell? Go for it. Let's hear it. I'm
kind of cringing cuz I'm worried about
what you guys are going to say.
>> [laughter]
>> But you know what
>> just a very funny. I understand he I
understand why he said he he's saying
he's trying to be trying to be honest,
trying integrity. You don't have to
explain your whole thought process the
whole way Connor. You know, I understand
you want to share that you're getting
divorced with your audience cuz you felt
you present yourself as a wife guy.
However, you really don't need to share
your whole thought process. Not
everything needs to be detailed here to
be honest. It's not dishonest to just
not tell your audience everything about
your life, really is it? Honesty is the
best policy. No. Don't bomb us. Okay.
Hold on. Let's see where the answers
come in. If you guys say no, no, no. Oh
god. Get congressional approval. Don't
say it. Do it. Depends on the bomb. I
want to know your secrets. How personal?
I don't need sizes. My heart isn't
ready. Opening the relationship, no.
Give me your secrets.
All right. Guys, I I should just do it.
I should do it. [__] it. Honesty,
integrity, right? Honesty, integrity. So
I'm going to totally [__] up the segment
in order to hit you with a personal
bombshell. So
Um [__] it. Let's just do it. So I think
that I represented myself as a wife guy.
Yeah. I I would agree with that.
>> am a wife guy. You are a wife guy. Okay.
>> So I loved, past tense, which I know is
going to scare you. Uh-huh. Uh I love
having a family. I love my kids
actively. I still love Mrs. Points. But,
what happened was in September, we
>> Already too much information, man. Rocky
Already TMI, you know. I understand why
you say this, but you know, I I hate to
do the commentary thing. I hate to do
the Chad thing. I hate to do the Nick
thing. Why you putting this on the
internet? Why you putting this on the
internet, man? Really, I really. I'm so
serious, bro. part of the relationship,
okay?
And it's a myriad of things. It's this
job. Style, you're going crazy.
>> politics. It's me getting So, guys,
Okay.
And it's a myriad of things. It's this
job. It's online politics. It's me
getting to work from home. So, he cites
YouTube and online politics as reasons
for his divorce, man. Again, why would
you Why would you put this on the
internet? I cannot stress enough.
Don't say that even could be true, don't
say that. Just don't say What are we
doing here, man? What are we doing here?
Uh it's some of the trauma from being in
law enforcement. It's some of the trauma
from, you know, her meeting me after uh
the military. It's the way that we were
raising our kids. It's the way that I
express myself.
So,
he says they hit a rocky patch in
September and it was related to online
politics and his job. What was going on
in September, man?
So, Charlie Kirk was around this time,
it seems like. Hmm. What could it have
been? What do What What content arc?
Dude, I need I need Connor on for the
divorce interview. Dude, do you think I
could get Connor to come on for the the
interview? Do you think he'd do it or
you think he'd tell me to [__] myself? I
don't know. It's no more rude than
anything else I've said to this guy. Can
I get the divorce interview?
>> [laughter]
>> Or is that [__] up to ask? I mean,
it's worth a try. It's worth It's worth
a try. I just knocked my water off the
[__] desk. It's worth a try, guys.
It's worth a try. We're giving it a go.
We're giving it a go. Maybe he tells me
to [__] myself. We'll see. We'll see. I
have to I have to know what coverage
What coverage does he think was
contributing the most to his marriage
problems? Was it the time she came in
and he was arguing the age of consent
with
elaborate MS Paint grids drawn out
explaining the sur- faces of sexual
[laughter] development and how weird it
would be if Destiny was attracted to
each one.
>> [laughter]
>> Do Do we think it was
I don't know about I want I have to know
though. I have to know. I need an
extended Counter-Points divorce segment
or an interview. I'm simply I am simply
too nosy, too virus-tic. I have to I
have to know. I have to know all this
kind of stuff. Yep. Yep, yep, yep, yep,
yep. Some of you guys are already
guessing it. So, uh we hit the rocks in
September and we were on the rocks for a
while. And then, I actually did not see
this coming, but in February she hit me
with papers, which sucks, okay? Um I
wasn't happy about it, but just being
real from my perspective,
okay? I left law enforcement for her
because she asked me to, okay? So, in
2019 she said, "Hey, like law
enforcement is [__] us up. You need
to leave the job because it's destroying
us." And so, I left law enforcement for
her, which was like a very big deal to
me, but there was like a lot of energy
around that incident. And I'm pretty
sure if you talk to her, too, uh she
would say that I articulated to her
multiple times, like she would
acknowledge how big of a sacrifice that
was, but
uh I don't feel like that actually
resonated in behavior. Because,
effectively, I took a career. I've told
you guys how difficult law enforcement
was.
Um it's a job that I loved, but didn't
love me back. And I basically burned it
for her. But, that wasn't enough um to
salvage the relationship. And so, we
made it, you know, for 6 years. I would
say we were together for 15 years.
Um I I was loyal, dutiful to one woman
for 15 years. And I don't regret
anything. I don't regret anything. I got
my kids. We had a lot of fun. We went on
adventures together. We did a lot of
serious [__] Um she helped me through a
lot of serious [__] So, I'm actually
like really grateful to her in a lot of
ways, and I articulated that to her.
Um I am, if I'm being honest, I'm a
little bitter and angry about some
aspects of it, because I was really
ready to like I was I was ready to go
for the next like four or five decades
and die uh with this woman. And she just
didn't want that, you know? And I hate
being such a [__] stereotype, but I
think
this is what therapy was. This is This
is legit for therapy. our relationship
is men marry women expecting that
they're not going to change, and women
marry men expecting that they will
change, okay? And so, she changed, and I
think she would admit that she changed
through the course of our relationship,
and I didn't. I'm the same guy that I In
my opinion, I am the same guy that I was
when I was 25, 24, when we met. And not
only am I the same guy, but I would say
that I'm like better in a lot of ways.
Like I I think I'm calmer, I think I'm
nicer, I
>> Okay, that is kind of what people
describe. Okay, whatever. I actually
like my job a lot.
>> Whatever. Um you know, I I think I'm
fairly patient. I try to be kind. I'm
not kind all the time. I can be quite
verbally abrasive. I think you guys know
that.
Um but anyways, she was just sick of my
[__] She was just sick of my autism.
So, she hit me with papers in February.
That's rough, man. That's [__] rough.
That's [__] rough, man. She's sick of
my autism. I I too too aggro, always
wants to argue, gets in arguments online
that stress her out cuz he she feels
like they look terrible. Life jacket
post a comment. I'm seeing it. Thank you
for the donor. Huge appreciate. Thank
you. Not very fun. Uh not going to lie.
I feel like the military and law
enforcement, I [__] you not.
Um getting divorced was and we just
finished this process within the past
couple of weeks. Um
getting divorced is seriously like top
three most tough things I've ever done.
And I'm still in the middle of it, too.
Like the the paperwork's done and like
the schedule is done,
but it's still very hard. And so, the
especially when you think you're going
to live and die with someone, you know,
like like you have like your life on a
track, you know? You you think that
you're going to live and die on this
track. And then God or life just kind of
throws you a [__] curveball. No,
babe. This is why we need to serve a
fascist police state emperor just like
in 40K. Thank you [laughter] for the $5.
And you're just like, what the [__] You
know? Although I do think God is God has
a pretty [__] strong sense of humor.
You know? And so, uh yeah, he's got a
pretty [__] up sense of humor. This is
God playing a sick joke on you, right?
>> Uh the point is that I I I hate Christ F
man. I hate Christ F so much. fidelity
issue on my end. It wasn't a fidelity
issue on her end. Uh we actually had a
pretty rich physical life in my opinion
for a very long time. It was literally
since September that [__] got on the
rocks. And so uh physically, mentally,
emotionally. Like I'm There were
problems before, right?
Um I don't know if I can watch this
stream. I'm getting second hand
embarrassment. This is painful. my
opinion. Uh we actually had I There is
honestly, honestly, there is a part of
me that, you know, in the same way I
like Mr. Girl, this is endearing to me
that he's just like saying all this
stupid crazy [__] It is is a little bit
endearing to you when someone just
[__] lays it all out. They're like,
[laughter]
"I'm getting divorced because of the
[__] I do online. My wife's leaving me
because I'm embarrassing myself on the
internet."
>> [laughter]
>> I'm like, "Okay. Tell me more. I want to
hear." had a pretty rich physical life
in my opinion for a very long time. It
was literally since September that [__]
got on the rocks.
Uh you love exhibitionists, you mean?
Like it.
I would be the voyeur. They uh
like an exhibitionist. So uh physically,
mentally, emotionally. Like I'm There
were problems before, right?
Um but those problems didn't really
stop, you know, us from being physical
or us having fun or us going on
adventures and all that kind of stuff.
And so, yeah. So, anyways, [__] up
the segment right now, but that's okay.
This is something serious that I
probably needed to tell you guys for a
while. I wanted to get through it.
>> Well, by the time
>> first. So, if you're like, "Hey, Connor,
you kind of alluded to the fact that the
wife was getting a different schedule.
You kind of alluded to the fact that
things were changing,
but you didn't really tell us what was
going on.
It's because I wanted to get through it
first. You know, I I didn't want to tell
you guys and then like [__] crash
out. I wanted to like hold my [__]
relatively together, get through it, and
then tell you, right? So, that that's
kind of why I kept it I kept it close to
the chest. So, anyways, um just to share
a little bit of the dynamic. Okay? Um
it's amicable as it can be,
you know? Uh-huh. Like obviously like a
breakup is never fun. And especially
when you have kids, it's a little bit
tough cuz you still have to see each
other, right? Um you still have to see
each other. So, like you you still see
each other at [__] drop-off and pick
up and all that kind of [__] And so,
you see, and uh I I hope my wife finds
this funny, ex-wife finds this funny.
You know, she was supposed She was
supposed to like divorce me and get
>> Wife Wife left and took the kids. Way
more time for what I'm having on
YouTube, am I right, man? Way more time
for what I'm having on YouTube now.
Let's [__] go. Wife left and took
Let's go. Let's go. uglier, you know?
>> [laughter]
>> She was She was supposed to divorce me
>> Oh yeah, brother.
>> and get uglier so I could be like
>> Jimbly Jimbly praying for this right
now. So, maybe one day he'll beat
compiler. Jimbly absolutely praying for
this right now.
>> [laughter]
>> Jimbly watching this like [__]
Ah, you know? Don't need that lady. She
dodged a bullet, you know?
>> [laughter]
>> to go back 4 seconds. I'll go back 20
seconds.
And so, you see, and uh I I hope my wife
finds this funny, ex-wife finds this
funny. You know, she was supposed She
was supposed to like divorce me and get
uglier, you know?
>> [laughter]
>> She was She was supposed to divorce me
and get uglier so I could be like,
"Ah, you know, don't need that lady. She
dodged a bullet, you know, F that broad,
blah blah blah blah blah." She was
supposed to get uglier so I could talk
[__] about her,
um
and she got prettier.
>> [laughter]
>> Which is very annoying. Um but I also,
you know, started working out and, you
know, Bro, this is so rough, man. This
is so [__] rough, dude. Holy [__]
man. Holy [__] bro.
He's on his knees begging for her back.
And bro, this is like so rough, dude. I
can't believe it.
>> cooking for myself and taking care of
myself a little bit. I can't believe I'm
hearing right now. I can't believe I'm
hearing right now, bro. It's like so
cliche. It's so [__] cliche.
I'm working out and I'm cooking for
myself and please come back.
Oh my god, I'm going to [__] lose it,
bro. Holy [__] this is too much. This
is too much.
Here [laughter] it is, still 25. He was
right. He was right. He was right.
Unfortunately, I fair, you know, there
may be many of us. There may [laughter]
be many of us. a little bit better than,
you know, happens in the
happens when you're running an entire
family. So like I've benefited
physically as well.
Um so, you know, that's why I'm going to
make an OnlyFans.
>> [laughter]
>> Here you go. What are What are we doing
here, man? What are we What are we doing
here, man? I thought about it. What are
we doing here, man?
Do I want to do a [__] face, you know?
Cuz arguably, I'm in my prime. I hadn't
watched this far. I hadn't watched this
far. Dude, I'm going to
>> [laughter]
>> [__] lose it. Holy [__]
Bro, this guy is so divorced, it's
crazy.
>> [laughter]
>> Someone
put this guy in a cell before it's too
late. Connor, you need to go in You need
to go in a cell for the next 5 years.
You're a danger to the public right now.
Holy [__]
>> [laughter]
>> I did not watch this far. I knew this
was going to be peak. I did not know
>> [laughter]
>> how [__] crazy this was going to be.
I literally shuddered. Dude, they even
fight us. He's legit He's going to He's
going to be like He's going to be like
Destiny now. He's going to be doing like
all bizarre polyamorous, sleeping with
18-year-olds that he meets online,
getting his [__] sex posted on the
internet. We actually may be in a new
era of Connor content. We may be in a
new era of Connor content, man. This
could be Yeah, new season. New season.
in in in a lot of ways. Like, obviously
my neck is [__] up, my back's [__]
up, I got PTSD, I'm copped out, all that
kind of [__] But, like, I have a cool
job, I have a cool life, I have, you
know, a lot of things going for me. I
have ambition.
>> okay, Connor. Connor. I don't know how
to break this to you.
Uh 200-viewer streamer is not a cool
job, actually. Two Like, two
200,000-viewer streamer Like, you know,
20,000-viewer streamer, cool job.
200-viewer streamer is not a cool job.
Thank you for the 10 pounds. We had
Thank you. Huge appreciated. Not
actually a cool job.
Um
No one's impressed by having a
200-viewer stream. I know this
firsthand. I know this firsthand,
Connor. So, just warning you. I don't I
I
Going to be real.
I think 200-viewer streamer is even less
cool at 50 than it is at 25. So, this
could be a problem. This could be a
problem for you, Connor. I'm not totally
ugly. Could I get out there and do like
a [__] face? And the answer is no.
>> [laughter]
>> I thought you said Yes, yes, I'm
rounding down my age and rounding up his
age. Correct. Yes, that's what we're
doing here. That's what we're doing
here.
All right. And so, what ended up
happening was I did download the dating
apps because basically even though this
entire process like wrapped up within
the past few weeks, like I said, I
haven't I haven't been intimate with
anybody since September of last year.
And
I don't need to know, man. I really I
really did not need to know.
I did not need to know, bro. Okay, look,
I feel we're missing so much here. Let's
wind this Let's really take this in,
guys. You know, cuz arguably I'm in my
prime in a lot of ways. Like, obviously
my neck is [__] up, my back's [__]
up, I got PTSD, I'm copped out, all that
kind of [__] But like, I have a cool
job, I have a cool life, I have, you
know, a lot of things going for me, I
have ambitions, I'm not totally ugly.
Could I get out there and do like a
[__] face? And the answer is no.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, no.
The answer is no. All right. And so,
what ended up happening was I did
download the dating apps because
basically even though this entire Bro,
this is like a [__] roller coaster,
man. This is like a [__] roller
coaster. This is some of the best
content I watched in ages. This is like
some of the best content I've seen in a
minute. I'm so invested. My my, you
know,
>> [laughter]
>> [__] I'm on a I'm on this roller
coaster of adrenaline. It's like up and
down. It's like, okay, he's he's backing
off and then he introduces something new
and you're like, "Whoa.
What's happening, Connor?" It's great,
man. This is heat. This is heat. Yes,
Connor, share your dating profiles.
Share your dating profiles. We need to
audit. Crowd-sourced auditing of
Connor's dating profiles. We'll We'll do
some critique streams. We'll go over
We'll give him some pointers. We'll get
the audience to chip in.
It'll be It'll be It'll be amazing.
It'll be so good.
entire [laughter] process like wrapped
up within the past few weeks. Uh like I
said, I haven't I haven't been intimate
with anybody since September of last
year.
And I knew this entire process was
coming.
And so uh basically, I was like, "Well,
I'm going to check out the dating apps
to see what's up." You know, especially
as we were getting towards the tail end
of the process.
And so I spent some time on the dating
apps. And so Bud123, I actually do feel
like I got a decent vibe for the dating
apps. And so that that's where my advice
is coming from is literally 2 weeks on
the dating apps. Because no offense to
people who use them. And if you use them
and you get dates and all that kind of
stuff, awesome. Like seriously, good for
you. Use the technology that you have in
order to date. But what I found is that
it effectively took the metaphorical
sexual marketplace and it made it very
literal. I mean, it's kind of true. made
it very
>> that's like obvious. You don't even need
to use the apps to like determine that,
right? You don't even need to use the
apps to determine that. That's like
just, you know, that's just kind of
follows. That's the way people kind of
act when, you know, they're given that
level of choice that's presented in that
way. People are treated that way. very
very literal. So I'm I'm going to go on
a yap about the the dating apps real
quick. So Okay, guys. This is great.
This is great. Connor's experience on
the dating apps, his read of the dating
apps
as a nearing 50 divorced man. Let's go.
This is heat. Bear in mind, I only have
You're like, "Which dating app?"
>> [laughter]
>> No. I didn't see my ex on the dating
app. Weirdly enough, I saw some friends.
>> [laughter]
>> Weirdly enough, I saw a couple of
friends. No, we're not getting a pile of
arc. I'm going to talk about that. And
actually, uh I'm I'm going to put a nice
wholesome bow like bow on the
>> of like like private like like shooting
himself? Is that what they're saying? Is
[laughter] that what they're saying? So
are they are they joking about being
Marine and shooting himself? Is that
what they're saying? Is that the joke
there? end of this.
>> a chat? Okay.
>> I can't see it. But let me let me tell
you my experience with the dating apps
real quick. [__] go full cam. So, Chat
was crazy, too, really? Hinge, Bumble.
Okay. Okay, this is a problem, I think.
That I don't think you should be using
Hinge in your 40s. I think that's a
problem. Why is a 40-something using
Hinge? I think that's a problem. That's
like a Noah Samson game. That's a Noah
Samson game. That's crazy. Bumble, I
don't know why, you know, to be honest,
anyone use that in the first place. The
idea of, you know, don't try you know,
it just the less women talk the better,
frankly.
I don't mean that. I don't mean that.
But it but it does it is [__] It is
a [__] idea. Um
yeah. I feel like why don't you use
Facebook dating? I feel like that's kind
of this age bracket. Facebook dating.
Facebook Stick to Facebook dating. And
Grinder. And Grinder. And all of the
dating apps that were serious dating
apps, where they market themselves as
like designed to be deleted, you know,
where they marketed themselves as the
adult place, I think they are oftentimes
female-oriented.
And so, I'm trying to go back and give
Bud123 sincere advice. My experience on
Bumble or Hinge, I forget which one,
and especially because I put myself in
as a 38-year-old, is the
uh
basically, it women that were
auto-filtered for me were women who were
looking for a serious relationship. They
were looking for their husband. And so,
what happened is I swiped and swiped and
swiped and swiped and swiped and swiped
and swiped. And truth be told I denied a
like I I did not swipe on a lot of
people, but I swept through all the
profiles that I had gotten.
And with the
>> like is he is he not 38? Is he Is that
not true? Do you like that his age? I
think he's like about his age. Yeah,
I'll be very popular on Grindr.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> But on Hinge and Bumble I found that the
people who were swiping on me for like,
you know, a thousand swipes, there would
be one mutual that I was actually
interested in going out on a date with.
And then you started the text
conversation. And then for the one
person that I would actually be
physically interested in, there were
three or four people who no offense,
like I'm really not trying to be that
rude, but they swiped on me and I was
like, nah. You know, like overweight,
missing teeth.
>> [laughter]
>> This is awesome. Guys, this is reminding
me of Have you ever seen Mr. Girl's uh
Tinder video? That's awesome, too.
That's awesome, too. This is very Mr.
Girl. This is all very Mr. Girl from
Connor, I'm not going to lie. This is
evoking a lot of Max Carson for me. Um
where where he's talking about There's
like a
>> [laughter]
>> I can't remember what what he says. He
He says some crazy [__] like he wants
like a 30-year-old in the body of a
teenager hasn't had a chance to ruin it
yet or some [__] like that. And he's
like sitting there scrolling on Tinder
like mumbling about this [__] And um
yeah, it just reminds me of that.
Instantly reminds me of that. physically
interested in, there were three or four
people who no offense, like I'm really
not trying to be that rude, but they
swiped on me and I was like, nah. You
know, like overweight, missing teeth,
probably smoke cigarettes.
>> every Chinese woman coming out of
shipping containers. You know, look like
they shop at Walmart. And I'm not trying
to be too I'm not trying to be like too
judgemental about it because obviously
like you can't control everything the
way that you look. But let's just say
that like if we were at a bar, I would
not have been trying to pick them up.
You know what I'm saying? So anyways, so
I found that the hinge
experience, the Bumble experience
actually really discouraging because of
that thing, right? And so
I just wasn't I wasn't getting the
results that I wanted. And then also
with like the one person that I was
actually interested in going on a date
with, it happened two or three times.
But what would happen is for the people
who weren't bots, we had like a texting
combo for a little bit. And then the
conversation just kind of dialed off.
And I would ask a direct question of
like, "Hey, do you want to go get
coffee? Do you want to do this?" And
they would kind of give me a non-answer.
And so eventually I was just like, "Eh."
Like they they're either talking to
other dudes and they have more
interesting prospects or they're just
not interested. Like maybe I tripped a
red flag or a yellow flag for them or
whatever. And so for whatever reason,
they're not expressing the level of
interest that I have in them back to me.
And so I'm not going to dump a ton of
energy into trying to like win their
affection because I feels cringe and
gay.
Um so I stopped doing that. Then with uh
Tinder, the reason why weirdly enough I
recommend Tinder over Hinge and Bumble
is I know
>> I'm not going to So he's saying he
doesn't he hates having to put like
disproportionate effort in. Is that what
he's saying basically? It feels like
he's announcing this so he can get in
the ego game. Doesn't sound like Tinder
worked out. Hmm. Is he No, there's no
there's not going to be like any egos
watching him. There might be some like
hags. There might be some like hags
watching him. not to be e-girls watching
them. He's on like uh this Valor Media
Network thing. It's like he's like paid
by This is run by like Midas Touch, you
know, the big lib media thing, and it's
basically content for like veterans is
the idea. The dem veterans.
So, there ain't no like e-girls
watching, I think. Although that it has
the reputation of a hookup app, but the
truth is that everybody's on Tinder. And
what I mean by that is like every kind
of person is on Tinder. So, there's like
finest [__] babe, gold Uh
I don't know. This could just be
geographical stuff. I feel like um but
is that really true? Is that really true
there's a wide variety of people on
Tinder? I don't know if that's true. I
I don't know what the numbers are. I
feel like Tinder's had like a decline,
though. Yeah, a noticeable decline.
Okay, Tinder is still the biggest dating
app, but I'd say. Yeah, I just I just
hear about Hinge way more. I just feel
like everyone The only way I hear about
now is Hinge. I don't hear about Tinder
anywhere near as much. Tinder is like a
boomer
uh dating app. God, that's where you
should I got that's where you should be.
Stick to Tinder. It is like It does
almost feel like it's a boomer dating
app, you know. gold diggers who are
looking for people to take them out and
spend tons of money on them. There's
super attractive chicks who are looking
either for like a hot hookup or they're
looking for their husband. Then there's
medium attractive chicks who have
personalities and they show off their
personalities on Tinder because like the
first picture I swear to god I could
give dating advice based off of 2 weeks
on the dating apps. First picture is
their face. Awesome. And they have a
pretty face. Second picture is a body
shot. And therefore, you can kind of
vibe on whether or not you're physically
attracted to them based off of the first
and second picture. Third and fourth
picture are aspects of their
personality. Maybe they ride horses.
Maybe they shoot guns. Maybe they go
fishing. Maybe they do something like
that. And typically, they'll post their
interesting pictures third, fourth,
fifth picture. And so, as a result, you
get a vibe for who they are. And so,
basically, like, what I found, sorry
about 1 2 3 to be giving you advice off
of 2 weeks of dating, but
what I found was that,
um,
basically, like, you can make an
instinctive judgment about whether or
not you're going to be attracted to
somebody and if it's a relationship
worth pursuing within a few seconds of
staring at somebody. But, as a result of
that, you really have to, like, looks
max and profile max your own [__] you
know? So, you have to post a face
picture that looks like a good angle of
your face because you're trying to get
people to click on your [__]
>> okay, I'm going to be real, I don't
think you actually have to go that hard.
I don't think it's that this is that
true. I don't I don't think you actually
have to go that hard. I don't I I agree
with the base analysis that the market
dynamics are
It is not so amplified that every little
thing is like super important. It's not
like you actually have to min max. As
long as you, like, I was going to say
don't come off like a total freak, but
even then, if you come off like a total
freak in the right kind of way, probably
still works. So, it's I don't even think
you you have to be trying that hard. You
know, I don't I don't think that's even
the case. Then, your second picture, in
my opinion, needs to be like a body
picture. It doesn't have to be naked. It
doesn't have to be half naked, but it
has to be a photo of you so people can
get a vibe for your body to see if they
want to see you naked. And then, third,
fourth, and fifth picture, in my
opinion, because face is the first thing
we're going to recognize, body is going
to be the second thing we recognize, and
then third, fourth, and fifth, it needs
to be personality pictures. I don't even
tell girls I'm a famous DJ. Yeah, it
gets an eyebrow. It's
And of course, there's like bios that
you can link, but people are only going
to read your bios if you make it past
the face picture and the body picture.
You know what I'm saying?
So anyways.
So I did go, just being very honest with
my experience. Um, I did not only find
somebody who was pretty enough that I
was interested in them, um, but we did
go on a couple of dates.
And uh, she was cool. She was uh, a
social worker. She worked at a local
hospital. Uh, she worked in the
behavioral unit and she Well, not maybe
the behavioral unit, I forget. Um, but
she was basically like a care
coordinator for poor people. Don't feel
sad. It's fine. Uh, I'll tell you I'll
tell you the good things in a minute.
I'll tell you the good things in a
minute, but I'm working up to the good
things.
And trust me, I'll tell you about my
split and the dynamics of the split, but
let me get through the dating. New kid
incoming? Not yet.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, he actually he does
Bro, dude, please don't tell me he talks
about his split over an hour. Bro, what
have I signed up for here?
Um, the I'm probably not going to have a
new kid, but I'll I'll tell you why in a
second.
I'm not sending people dick dick pics,
no. So, the uh,
the the care coordinator, her job is
actually like if there's somebody at the
hospital
and they come back to the hospital
within 30 days,
then effectively the hospital gets like
a statistical
mark against them because they didn't
give them sufficient medical or social
uh, support in order to avoid ending up
getting re-hospitalized.
So her job was not only to coordinate
the medical care for people afterwards,
but also to um, basically coordinate
their like social support afterwards to
make sure that they weren't
re-hospitalized.
And so, while the medical care system is
kind of [__] up, she was doing a
really cool job within the medical care
system.
And so, you know, she was pretty, she
had tattoos, she worked in the medical
care field, she was really kind. Um she
was a good person. She was a good person
overall. But basically after a couple of
weeks and a couple of dates, um she
wasn't um interested in pursuing the
relationship because basically I hit one
of her yellow flags and that triggered a
red flag for her. And she expressed this
like very emotionally intelligently to
me. And so, I'm not mad. I'm not mad at
all. She She did a great job
communicating
the thing that I stepped on her toes,
which by the way, like to me it wasn't a
big deal, but to her it was a big deal.
And so, as a result, I, you know, I just
triggered, you know, something that, you
know, was from her past that didn't
really
Hey, I had a lot of fun, but this isn't
for me. And I was like, okay, that's
fine. So, uh bear in mind this is all
been very recent. Everything that I'm
describing to you happened within the
past month or so. So, after that,
funnily enough, I'm going to get into
the things that are I'm going to
describe where I'm at right now and then
I'm going to describe the familial
dynamic. So, I know it's kind of weird
to prioritize my dating life over my
familial dynamic, but the familial
dynamic more has to do with logistics
that's going to affect you guys. Um so,
I'm going to describe my current dating
situation before I continue. So, since
it didn't work out with the Orlando
health social worker, who was very nice
and we had a great time, but I just
wasn't her guy and she might not have
been my gal, so that's okay. The I I
remembered somebody who was local who,
weirdly enough, this this is going to be
like kind of wholesome, so I want you
guys to put on your wholesome pants and
I want a solid
>> Hey, this is literally every this is
like such a post breakup thing to do.
But I I don't I didn't realize like
40-year-olds do that when they were
getting divorced. Cuz I'm thinking, oh
well, what women that are like, you
know, kind of in the area of that right
now I kind of had an interaction with
that seemed like it go somewhere at some
point in the like last 10 years.
Who can I hit up?
I did [snorts] not realize 40-year-olds
do this. That's crazy. Just to stop
being depressed real quick. So, my first
girlfriend ever. Dude. Okay. Going back
to the first girlfriend, it's [__]
over. It's [__] over, dude. It's
[__] over. I'm ex-I'm actually in the
Stella behind the bookcase screaming
right now. Connor, Connor, no.
>> [laughter]
>> Connor.
Dude.
>> [laughter]
>> I can't believe this, man. This is so
[__] up.
>> [snorts]
>> Holy [__]
>> [laughter]
>> Please Please don't tell me, bro. Come
on.
>> stop being depressed real quick. So, my
first girlfriend ever. Okay? Ever. And I
I want to describe that to you real
quick. I moved from Belgium to Or wait,
hold on. I moved from Boston to Florida,
Florida to Belgium, to Texas, Texas to
Florida. Okay?
Beef Supreme, literally the opening of
this rant is that the Mrs. Points and I
split. So, rewind about 20 minutes and
you'll get caught up, okay? So, um what
ended up happening was I remember that
she was local. Guys, if you're coming in
late, my wife left me.
Uh so, hold on. I'll hold on. Uh Texas
to Florida.
>> That's the content today. So, there was
this girl that when I was 15, okay,
literally 15, okay?
>> Bro, this is Oh,
man. We uh went out on a couple of
dates, but we were 15, so we didn't do
anything. We probably kissed like two or
three times. We went to this place um
Orlando people might literally remember
it, but there was this place called Rock
Haven, okay?
And Rock Haven is a place where like
teenagers go to booty dance to music
that's way too loud.
And we went there when we were like 14
or 15 and we booty danced and I was
like, "This is
way too vulgar for my conservative
Christian upbringing."
>> [laughter]
>> Yo, huge appreciate Caesar with the $50.
>> cool face emoji. Thank you so much. Huge
appreciate. Thank you. Thank you. Guys,
that is hugely generous, but I would
just remind you off the back of that, if
you are enjoying this content, remember
to support the stream, make you Make
sure that I can keep uh you know,
keeping up with Connor's marriage and
and post-marriage troubles, okay? If you
If you want more content like this,
remember to donate. Remember to like the
stream.
But we had a good time. We had a good
time. And so, we had a good time, but I
didn't have a car and so, my parents
were driving Yeah, my my parents uh were
driving me
uh to her house. First you're married
and now you are divorced. That one guy
was right, you're so inconsistent.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, I hope that's a reference. Um so
anyways, so my parents were driving me
over to her house to take her out on a
date and what ended up happening was uh
I was embarrassed that my parents kept
having to drive me. And she lived like
20 minutes away. So, since I was so
embarrassed of having to being driven to
her house, I was like, "Hey, I don't
think this is going to work." But what's
funny about that is I got her earrings
for Christmas and she still has
>> choked on my water. Holy [__] Which is
hilarious cuz like 20 years later
>> Broke up with a girl because you you
were getting driven around by your
parents. That is awesome. She still has
the earrings. So,
uh anyways, so I realized that she was
local and I DM'd her and I was like,
"Hey, I know this is like a shot in the
dark. We haven't talked in like 20
years. Uh are you still with your
husband?" Because she
What an amazing opener. What an amazing
opener. Hey, we haven't spoken in 20
years. Are you divorced?
uh was married and like I knew that she
was married. It Her husband actually
went to my high school.
Um
But like I'd seen her at the grocery
store and I thought she was cute. And so
I DM'd her and I was like, "Hey, you
know, are you still married? Whatever.
Blah blah blah blah blah." Total shot in
the dark. It like, "Are you still local?
Are you still married?" And she was
like, "No.
Actually, I got divorced about 6 years
ago. Still got my kids. We're still
raising our kids together. We're still
split, etc. etc. Dude.
>> But I'm local. And
um so basically, I was like, "Okay, are
you single?" And there was like a little
dance around that where like she was
trying to I think she was trying to
figure out if I was trying to cheat on
my wife [laughter] or not because like
all my social media was still like, you
know, pictures of the family and picture
of me and the wife and picture of this.
And I'm not going to delete any of those
pictures. That's a part of me. That's a
part of my life. That's a part of my
history. And so
>> Bro. um you know, she was trying to
figure out if I was trying to cheat on
my wife and I was like, "No, no, no, no,
no." You know, wife and I split.
Um you know, we're going through it, but
you know, we're getting through the end
process and blah blah blah blah blah.
And so I would like to I would like to
take you out on a date. And so she said
yes. And she is pretty. I like her face.
I like other aspects of her. I'm not
trying to be vulgar, but I but I do like
other aspects of her and I've expressed
those things to her. She's very nice.
And This guy says way too much.
>> does a very noble profession, okay? She
works with and I joked about this
multiple times. She works with severely
autistic children. So she's a behavioral
specialist in the local school system.
And that well, kind of then perfect
skill set to be married to you then
clearly. Thank you Jim Roe for the $10
with the Shiba Inu hugging the heart.
Thank you. Huge appreciate.
>> So her job is to work with like severely
autistic kids. And I'm not talking about
like you. I'm not talking about my chat.
I'm talking about like kids who like
piss themselves, [__] themselves, don't
have the ability to communicate, don't
have the ability to sit, throw tantrums,
throw things, fling things, and all that
kind of stuff. And she works with them
every single day. And so her days are
kind of rough, but she loves it, okay?
And not only does she love it, but she
has a very like noble spirit about this.
And I'm I'm going to I'm going to tell
you like a a story. Yeah, the the joke I
will say the joke eventually, okay? As a
matter of fact, I'll just say it. Her
her dealing with severely autistic
people every single day
is like going to be a boon to our
relationship. Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh-huh. She literally deals with
severely autistic kids every single day.
So my level of autism is fine.
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's perfect, you know? I have the
fun autism. She works with autistic
people all day.
Perfect match.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh [__] So anyways,
um
>> [laughter]
>> Everybody in chat gets it. Yeah, yeah.
>> So so so so so so so. Um weirdly enough,
we we sat there cuz we we did go on a
date recently. And we went to like a
local tea house, local sandwich joint,
you know, all that kind of all that kind
of stuff. And she she she has tattoos. I
have tattoos. So we're just talking,
we're yapping. She's a smart girl.
Um she's a very smart girl. And she has
her master's
>> Smart girl. 38-year-old woman. Smart
girl. 38-year-old woman. system, and she
doesn't make that much money, but she
has this like really really noble job.
And I love her noble job. And and I want
to tell you a little bit more because I
am uh I'm crushing a little bit on some
of this stuff. So I asked her because
like for me like working with like
autistic people or working with our
slurs, like developmentally disabled
people, it's very noble, but it's also
very tough. Because with law
enforcement, you can like take them on,
but then you pass them off to somebody
else, you know? So that already is
incredibly stressful. And so taking them
and if taking them on and then passing
them off to somebody else is incredibly
stressful. She's the person that is
they're getting passed off to. She's the
person who has the ultimate end result.
And so well, she uses the R slur, too,
so don't worry about it.
>> [laughter]
>> Not in reference to her kids, okay? Not
in reference to her kids, in reference
to me.
>> [laughter]
>> So anyways, so anyways, um I was like,
"Why do you do it? You know, like they
there's piss and [__] and blood and
biting and screaming and all this
horrible [__] Why why do you do it? You
know, like like how do you keep doing
this? It sounds so [__] tough. And so
she's like because I will work with a
kid on a behavior for like months, okay?
And so I will literally have a kid who
cannot
can't can't like sign that they want for
help, right?
And so they literally like they will
throw things, grab things, [__] smash
things,
piss themselves, [__] themselves, bite
people trying to get attention because
they have a problem, right? And so if
you can help them communicate their
problems, it can totally change the
trajectory of their life. So for
instance, she brought up that there was
this kid, you know, tantrums, pissing,
[__] all that stuff. And she after
working with this kid for months was
able to get him to sign that he needs
help, okay?
And so as a result of getting him to be
able to sign like go to a place instead
of throwing a tantrum, going to a place,
sitting down in a designated place, and
then signing that he needs help, they
basically cut down on like a substantial
amount of the negative behaviors. Like
the pissing, the [__] the biting,
the fighting, all that kind of stuff.
All of that's been chopped by like 90%
because this kid can ask for help. And
not only does that like bring a
wholesome tear to my eye,
but we also talked about it from the law
enforcement perspective because if that
person becomes an adult and they're
[__] and pissing themselves and
biting people and throwing tantrums and
all that kind of stuff, when when you're
doing that as a child,
people will go out of their way to help
you because you're a child. But when
you're an adult, you could get [__]
shot for doing that. And so she
she sees her job as so necessary
and beautiful and cool because she is
the person who makes that difference in
their life.
And so she will deal with the biting,
the pissing, the [__] the fighting,
the screaming, the throwing furniture,
the weird threats, the outbursts and the
tantrums because she knows that she gets
to have that impact. And I I just think
that's so admirable. Like truly
admirable. Separate from any
relationship uh that I have with her.
And so um basically that that's my deep
admiration. And so we were going over
tattoos. We you know we got some food,
we got some sandwiches, we got some tea,
we were hanging out, we were yapping.
And then I'm kind of taking this as a
sign from God, you know, that that this
is just who I'm supposed to talk to and
to who I'm supposed to date at this
point in my life. So she has a tattoo of
a starfish on her wrist. Okay. Uh-huh.
And she says, "Have you ever heard the
story of the starfish?" Wow. And I was
like, "Hold on because this is one of my
two favorite parables ever." I I think
I've told you guys this multiple
multiple multiple times. And I was like
"I'm going to describe the parable of
the starship or starfish, excuse me.
And it Yeah, that you won't make the
joke. It's just too obvious.
>> If you say it if you say that this is
the parable, like that's going to blow
my [__] mind off. Like like like I'm
I'm just going to have my entire mind
blown. So obviously I've told you guys
this before.
Um my the shorter story is the uh the
German stick saying of even if the world
were to end tomorrow I would plant an
apple tree today, which I think is
amazing. It it captures the cynicism of
the Germans, but it also captures How
full of horse [__] are you, Harrison?
even if everything's falling apart.
That's one of my favorite sayings. My
other favorite saying, which I've told
you guys multiple times over the past
year, is it's a parable. So there's a
young man on a beach, there's a thousand
washed up starfish, he picks up a
starfish, he throws it into the ocean,
and then he picks up another one, throws
it in the ocean, picks up another one,
throws it in the ocean, and then an old
man walks by and he says, "There's a
thousand of them. You're not going to
get to all of them. Um you're you know,
you're wasting your time. What what
you're doing doesn't matter." And then
the young man, undeterred, picks up
another starfish and throws into the
ocean and he says, "It mattered to that
one." And so, it's the statement of our
orientation within existence that we can
look at the overwhelming nature of the
world's problems and say ultimately that
we as individuals don't have Um isn't
this your boy? Shouldn't you cut him
some slack?
The last interaction I had with Connor
of any substance was us both in DMs
accusing each other of normalizing
pedophilia. And I've just reached out
and asked him for the divorce interview.
So, have an impact, and therefore, you
can become a nihilist hedonist or a
cynic and not try to have a positive
impact in the world. Whereas, you know,
the young boy, the person that we should
idolize,
is uh saying, "Well, it mattered to that
one, okay?" And so, she's like, "Yes."
That's the story. No, do me, it's not a
meme. He's just We've just watched like
an hour of Connor talking about his
divorce, the fact that it's related to
online politics, and his job, uh how
upset he is over it, his experience
using Tinder in the wake of his divorce.
It's been It's a ride, do me. It's a
real ride, man. And so, at that point,
I'm just like, "I don't even give a [__]
like about anything else." That's such
like a positive orientation of the way
that you should be in life. Also, he's
gotten back with his first girlfriend
from when he was 15.
That I was like,
"I'm yours, you know? Like, can I be
your boyfriend?
>> [laughter]
>> That was literally Literally like first
date, even before the first date. I was
like, "Hey, listen, can we just like yap
together? See if we have physical
chemistry.
>> [laughter]
>> If we have physical chemistry, can I be
your boyfriend?" And she was like,
"Yep."
>> [laughter]
>> So So Yeah. Then you started making out.
Not immediately. Not I need the state to
take this guy's YouTube channel away. I
need him to be legally stopped from
talking online. immediately. But
anyways, so so the point is like this is
all happened in the past since September
and I only signed papers in late April,
okay? The the deal, which I will go over
with you guys, is signed in the late
April.
He's going to go over the divorce
agreement. See, we I'm in a I'm in a
weird spot, okay? Because obviously, I'm
getting older, man. I'm in my late 30s.
I'm in my early 40s or, you know, I'll
be in my early 40s soon enough. And so
I'm in a weird spot because I have my
kids that I love. It was a very short
[__] phase, correct. It was very
short. Um but but the [__] phase,
which my friend Corbin Sales is going
through as a young man in his 20s, is
just not as appealing to me, you know?
Like if you could guarantee that I would
exclusively date,
you know, eights who are mentally and
emotionally like eight pluses, let's be
real, you know, eights through 10s who
are mentally and emotionally mature, who
are capable of having a physical
relationship, calling it quits when they
wanted to,
uh being serial monogamous while we're
together, and I was just going to date
eights and 10s for the rest of my life
who were emotionally mature, capable of
serial monogamy, and therefore life
could be a cornucopia
of sexual [__] until I died, then maybe
I would be considering a [__] phase.
But that's not how it works. The The way
that the [__] phases work in my mind
is you find profoundly damaged people
because we're all damaged. I'm damaged.
Uh my girl is damaged. My wife is
damaged. And we hurt each other, right?
We We We
>> My girl. 4-year-old They say 4-year-old
white man say my girl my girl. Not on
purpose, but we hurt each other. And so
you kind of build up this like uh this
history of trauma. And so being able to
like bounce into each other having fun
sex and then bouncing away from each
other is not how it works. How it works
is typically if you bump into Let's just
say everybody's uh attractiveness is
subjective. But a seven to you or an
eight to you or a nine to you or a 10 to
you. When you bump into that person and
then you're going for a casual sexual
liaison, typically if you guys do a
casual sexual liaison, it's because
they're drunk or they have trauma or
they're recovering from a breakup or
they're going through their [__]
[__] phase because they're young or
something like that. And there's going
to be some emotional turmoil associated
with that sluttiness
that um as a result is going to mean
that the hookup is going to be a little
messy.
And then the breakup's going to be a
little messy. Beef Supreme says not all
of us [__] are damaged. Some of us are
just uh [__] in our hearts.
Maybe, but doubtful. Uh I bet that if we
went through your personality, we would
be able to find endless [__] trauma,
Beef Supreme. No offense.
Um so yeah. So So, basically, in my
opinion, the the options are burn a
faithful relationship with a genuinely
kind-hearted person who I find
attractive inside and outside. I don't
think I'm projecting at all. I think
this is based off of experience, not
projection. But anyways, um so I could
totally like torch this relationship in
order to pursue like a [__] phase, or
I could just be loyal and kind and
dutiful and have fun and and have like a
good friend and good other stuff and you
know, all that kind of stuff. And um so
I'm I'm going down that path. So, who
who knows? You know, obviously like the
split is very recent. This relationship
is very recent. Uh she has, you know,
baggage from her marriage. I have
baggage from my marriage. Um so it's
very young. Who knows? I could literally
be bitching to you in like 6 months and
be like, "Oh, Chad, this thing happened
and now everything's [__] up."
>> why would you do But why would you do
that? Okay, but why would you do that?
>> in 6 months, but I really hope that I'm
not, you know? I really hope that I'm
not. I really hope that, you know, I'm
I'm having fun and I'm in a new
relationship where my autism and her
personality
>> me specifically.
and her orientation towards service and
my orientation towards service lead to,
you know, a a compatibility that allows
us to
have a a long-term relationship that's
fruitful and good. So, that's also scary
though. And I'll tell you the reason why
it's scary just as like a late 30
38-year-old guy. The reason why it's
scary is because like you kind of want
to have the love of your life, right?
And that that's kind of like what you
want to do. You want to find your Romeo
and Juliet. You want to find the person
who sets your blood on fire. You want to
find this. You want to find that. And
I'm not saying that we couldn't have
that. I'm just saying like you want to
find uh the love of your life and you
kind of want to like live and die with
them, so to speak. But, I don't I think
that's way easier said than done. And
What profound revelations have it, 40
years old? life is way more [__]
complicated than that. And so, yeah. I'm
not going to be like constantly on the
prowl
looking for someone who's better than my
partner, so I can have this like
rapturous Romeo and Juliet [__] love
story. And I'm also not going to be
being a [__] because I don't like it.
It's not fun for me. And so, I'm just
going to take it. I'm just going to take
it day by day, you know? Yeah, they were
dumb [__] kids who ended up killing
themselves. Exactly. Exactly. You know,
there's something to be said for
rapturous love.
>> For the membership credit, thank you.
Huge appreciate. Thank you. on fire.
There's also
because I'm older, you know, I've had
rapturous love not only set my soul on
fire, but
you know, also like, you know, destroy
things.
>> [laughter]
>> So, like rapturous love is is a
double-edged sword.
So, anyways, Uh-huh. the reason why I
wanted to share this with you guys is
because like I am kind of like moving
out of it, you know?
I'm kind of like I'm moving out of my
current and I should get into the
familial dynamic momentarily. Um but,
I'm kind of like I'm
>> Dude, the condom mail order bride arc.
Holy [__] out of
>> content. my current familial dynamic
into a new familial dynamic. And then,
I'm also moving into a new relationship
that I hope I hope is um healthy and
happy and fun and cool. And I hope that
it's long-term. There's no reason why it
wouldn't be long-term on my end, and she
has expressed similar sentiments, but of
course life is a little bit
is a little bit more complex than that.
It's a little bit more complex than
that. So, who knows? Who knows what the
next 6 months hold? Once again, I will
reiterate, I felt like my life was on a
track. You know, I felt like
you know, my my ex's name is Victoria. I
thought it was
Victoria and me, you know, we're
married. I'm annoying as [__] but she's
going to put up with my annoying stuff.
She has some, let's call them
personality quirks that I will tolerate
because she puts up with my personality
quirks.
>> Mhm. We will
our quirks, let's just call them
tactfully quirks. We will tolerate each
other's quirks, and will run out the
next few decades of life together
because we're friends, and we're lovers,
and we're co-parents, and we're this,
and we're that. Um so, even if our lives
aren't perfect, and we're not perfect
partners, we are partners for life, and
we're going to live and die together.
That's what I thought I signed up for.
Uh but, like I said, we hit the rocks in
September. She, you know, kind of was
trying to work her way through it.
She hit me with papers in February, and,
you know, it is what it is. I don't want
to
I don't want to force somebody to be
with me in spite
of things that they think are going to
like grade on their soul over years or
decades. I I want I want whoever I'm But
but but God said but God said if you
truly want to spend time with me, and so
I don't want it to be I don't want to
have to form myself into a different
person
in order to meet their ever-increasing
standard of who they want to be with.
And I also don't want to if I fail to
meet that standard, I don't want there
to be like a brooding resentment of me
not being the thing that they wanted me
to be, and then for that to just like be
corrosive on the relationship in
perpetuity. It just It's not It's not
worth it.
It's not worth it. So, sucks, but um it
is what it is. Best advice for me, take
everything slow. This is a new stage,
don't rush anything, get grounded and
secure, and don't bite off more than you
can chew. I'm going slow-ish. I'm going
slow-ish. And I guess we should get into
the familial dynamic real quick.
So, just being real,
uh
we could have done 50/50 uh with the
kids and with the house and called it a
day, but Victoria wanted um more
substantive custodial
relationship with the kids. And I wasn't
necessarily opposed to that. She's been
their primary caretaker in like their
entire lives.
Uh so, I didn't concede very much, but I
conceded a little bit for the sake of
amicability
um and and her desires. So, what
happened was just being very
straightforward, it's 60/40. Could have
been 50/50, but it's 60/40. So, I have
my kids uh 1 week, I have them 2 days a
week, and then I have like visitation
that I can do. Um and then I have them
another week 3 days a week. So, out of a
14-day period, I think I have them eight
or nine days.
Um you know, once you added like the I
can visit them at any time kind of
stuff.
Um
and so, oh wait, hold on. Or is it the
inverse? I think out of a 14-day period,
I have them five to six days.
That's how that works. Yeah. And so,
Yeah, the other way around. Basically
that. And so, one one week I have them
Wednesday, Thursday, and I can visit
them on the weekend. And then the other
week I have them Friday, Saturday,
Sunday. So, when I was telling you guys
that like, "Oh yeah, Victoria's going to
like a new job schedule and which is
true by the way, she's also changing
jobs.
Um but basically every other weekend is
going to be the weekend that I can do
community stuff. You know what I'm
saying? Uh because I'll be chilling.
Now, the truth is I had so much post
recorded work to do this past week.
Every other weekend is what I can do
community stuff. I By the way, do I have
to take kids? I can hang out on Discord
all day.
>> [laughter]
>> Let's go.
Let's go.
weekend that it didn't even cross my
mind to do a community night.
so [laughter] much [__] to do. Um but
once I get settled into the new
schedule, we'll be fine. And and I I
might start doing like a community night
every other Saturday night. Uh the boys,
some people were asking about the boys.
Uh the boys are doing okay, all things
considered. Um and I'll share a few fun
That sounds great. Thank you $5, Samson.
Thank you.
>> all that bad. All Connor needs to do is
develop whole new personality and find
the fountain of youth and he's set.
Thank you. Thank you. anecdotes. So, I
asked my oldest because this process has
been unfolding for the past 2 months. I
asked my oldest, I was like, "Hey, how
would you rate your life on a 1 to 10?"
And he's like, "Nine." And I was like,
"Damn, that's pretty [__] good. Okay,
all things And he is upset. He is upset.
He's expressed how upset he is about
this process, but he still is rating his
life out of out of nine out of 10. So,
I'm like, "Okay, that's good." Then,
um Victoria is staying in a place with a
pool and I love to swim and my boys love
to swim and I have a local pool that I
go to. And so, basically the boys are
ecstatic because they get to hang out
with their grandparents pretty
frequently on that side of town. They
get to go to a pool very frequently on
that side of town. And uh also at my
place, we get to go to the pool very
frequently. And then they get to play My
older child gets to play video games
like a [__] Like he he he'll
just he'll play video games endlessly
and he loves to play video games and I
borderline encourage that because I was
a gamer as well. Ah, so yes, uh my
children do get upset sometimes when
we're like transitioning the kids from
one location to another, but they're
excited to see me, I'm excited to see
them, I love them, that hasn't changed
at all. And then my oldest, like I said,
this did shake him a little bit, but I
think the fact that he basically gets to
like go party
with grandma and grandpa and mommy and
go swimming and have a cool place to
hang out on that side of town, and then
he gets to come to daddy's house and we
get to [__] play video games and go
swimming and all that kind of [__] um
he's doing okay all things considered.
And then my youngest, I'll just be real,
he's 3 years old, he doesn't give a
[__]
>> [laughter]
>> I'm just going to be real. He doesn't
care.
Like he was already a fairly a very
fiercely independent child. Like he was
already
like if we were playing with him,
hanging out with him in the backyard,
and he wants to go do something, and
we're like, "Hold on, Henry, give me a
second, you know, let me go do this."
He's like, "Eh." And then he just goes
and does it by himself. He's already
like a wildly independent child. And so
what's funny is there is a little bit of
tension during like the pick up and drop
off, where he's excited to see mom and
so he runs away and gives her a hug and
then he tells, you know, "Hey, dada,
come on." Um
you know, and then but I but I don't and
he gets a little upset when I don't tag
along. And then vice versa, you know, he
runs to me and he's really excited to
see me. Um and then he wants mommy to
come along and then she can't come
along. So, you know, there's like a
little bit of tension there, but at the
same time like it's great, you know? Uh
you know, I still have a great Is that
Is that
>> relationship with my boys and I plan on
being intentional
fostering that,
trying to spend good time together,
trying to make sure that my place, just
being real,
my place is a place of anarchy and fun,
okay? Okay, he's trying to be the cool
dad. He's trying to be the cool dad.
Oh my god.
Yo, source of awesome, huge appreciative
of the 10 gifted. That's
usually generous of you.
Thank you so much. This is rough.
There's some of this is just bleak. Some
of this is just like, [__] man.
But obviously, like I'm not going to let
my children do anything dangerous, but
they're going to have fun here. They're
going to play with video games, they're
going to play in the dirt, they're going
to chase lizards, they're going to walk
the dogs, we're going to go to the local
park, we're going to go to the pool,
we're going to do all this crazy [__]
We're going to have a lot of fun and
yeah.
Yeah, yeah. So, so I want my place to be
like the let your hair down and go crazy
place. And then it's not that we have no
rules. You still have to do your
homework, you still have to brush your
teeth, you still have to read a book,
you still have to do this, you still
have to do that. But
it's more fun than mom's.
Just be Just being real.
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to be
more fun than mom's house.
I'm like having like an aneurysm or
something. I think this is like
I'm struggling. I'm really struggling.
This is like bad. This is like really
bad.
>> [laughter]
>> We eat more candy, we eat more carbs, we
eat more fat, we run around. They're
basically Tasmanian devils who destroy
my common areas over the course of 48
hours. You know, they just absolutely
annihilate
my living room and my kitchen every time
they
every time they come over, they just
absolutely annihilate my common area.
And so basically like when they leave, I
spend about a day wallowing in the
destruction that they've made, but it's
fun destruction. And then I clean, mop,
or clean, vacuum, and mop, and then the
house is ordered for another few days
until they come back. So, yeah. All that
sounds really good. It is. It's a mixed
bag. Obviously like it it's sad. You
know, 15 years is nothing to shake a
stick at, you know, that's almost like a
That's almost like a like a military
contract. Like my my wife and I
>> was Food Shops right now, I'd be
planning my next two streams of this.
That's so facts, bro. That's so facts.
>> We almost completed a military contract
together, but we just didn't have the
stuff to to make it last the entire way,
which sucks.
But um I can't resent that. You know, we
we've lived We lived in three places
together. We had at our peak, we had
four dogs, but we probably had five or
six dogs
over the course of our decade and a half
together. We lost some of those dogs
together. We've gone on adventures.
We've gone to theme parks. We've
traveled. We, you know, we obviously
have two kids that we both love to
pieces.
It's sad to me and it's upsetting to me
that we're no longer together, but it's
you know, like I'm hoping that I can
relatively ignore her moving on
romantically. Oh my god. I'm going to
try to be like an asexual robot, you
know, in her mind.
I'm going to try to be an asexual robot
in her mind, and I'm hoping that she you
know, we've talked about it. I'm hoping
she's doing me the courtesy as well,
where effectively I will not hear about
her boyfriends unless she is marrying
someone. Like they're not going to meet
the kids. My, you know, my girlfriend's
girlfriend are not meeting the kids
unless it's like super long-term
borderline remarriage. That's the only
time that
any romantic partner that she has will
be on my radar is effectively when it's
somebody that she's considering
marrying. So, and and I will try to do
the same courtesy.
It's tough. It's tough. As you
continually casually date
>> Bro, it is just like You can see the
pain in his eyes and [__] man. It's
crazy. I'm not casually We're We're not
casual.
I am a serial monogamous person, so I'm
going to be monogamous and loyal to my
new girlfriend, and she has expressed a
similar interest. So, you know,
obviously I'm not like a psychic, so I
don't know 100% that she's loyal to me,
but she has like a very busy life. So, I
think the chances of her playing me are
pretty low. So, yeah. And I mean, that's
life, too. So, if if something crazy or
[__] up happens, I'll let you guys
know. Anonymous chatter says, "Connor,
I'll start sending you recipes so you
can have some solid meals." Honestly,
man, I can cook. But like I can't cook
to a female standard, but chicken and
rice is not hard. Orange chicken and
rice is not hard. Picking up a sushi
platter from Publix is not hard.
Spaghetti is not hard. Cheeseburgers are
not hard. You know, it's actually, you
know, no offense to the the females in
our [__] audience, but you know, like
she was a stay-at-home mom, and
obviously I I'm not trying to like Hate.
reduce the work that she did. Like like
I'm not trying to reduce the work that
she did, but I swear to god, sometimes
females act like [__] cooking and
cleaning is [__] slavery. And when
you're cooking and cleaning for one
person,
>> Dude, this is You just know chores were
an issue in the relationship. Favorite
of the two dollar Samson. You just know
chores were an issue in the
relationship. I've said I've It's coming
through so clearly. Say less, Connor.
Say less. Say less, buddy. Every guy has
been there, okay? Every guy has been
there. But, say less, okay? Don't cope
about it. Don't cope about it. Listen,
it's really not that big of a [__]
deal. So, no offense. Sorry. I'm not
trying to demean Like, your wife left
and you're talking about going picking
up sushi platters. Like, [laughter]
it's not that hard. Like, you
You're not actually doing it. You're not
cooking. You're not cooking, [__] She
had to feed probably herself, you, your
two kids. You're feeding you, dude. You
should You can go just pick some [__]
up. You haven't got to look after
anyone. You're on your own. Come on now.
Cleaning for four people or five people.
I'm sure that gets annoying. I'm sure
that gets frustrating. I'm sure that
feels like a Sisyphian task.
But, um no, dude. Cook cooking and doing
the dishes and wiping the counters every
single night and then vacuuming and
mopping once or twice a week and
organizing the common area is not that
difficult. So, sorry. I'm sorry. I know
that I know that some people live in
filth, but I'm too old for that [__]
So, just get off your [__] duff and
do it. Bud123 says, "Also, it's common
for guys on Hinge to get no likes and to
only match with women that like I like
first with uh thoughtful comments. I
have zero likes and matches in a day."
Yes, it is, Bud123. And seriously, I'm
I'm borderline recommending you get on
Tinder because I think that So, with
Tinder, this is this is the way that I
understand it, okay? Bear in mind, I'm I
I'm bringing 2 weeks of dating advice to
you. But, this was the vibe that I got.
And this is how I think it works. So, on
Tinder, you're going to set a geographic
zone of 100 miles. And you're going to
set your age bracket from literally 19
or 20 to 40, okay? I don't know how old
you are. If you're
>> You will set it to
25 miles and you will set your age to 18
to 25. Your late 20s, set it to 32 or
33.
Set it to the maximum amount of age
and actually some really attractive
>> [laughter]
>> girls out there. Set it to the maximum
age
that you would be willing to date
casually or seriously, you know? And
then basically just swipe. And and I'm
not kidding. There are This is going to
be very rude and if you are an
overweight six and or a trans girl,
please know that I still love you as I
say this, okay?
There are a lot of overweight sixes and
a lot of trans girls.
>> [laughter]
>> Like I'm really I'm really not trying to
be mean, but I swear to God Why does guy
live? 100 people
>> no, no, no, no, I ask you that in like a
weird way. I'm just saying like, you
know, what the [__] is this experience,
you know? There might be five, maybe 10
people that I would actually want to
date. And there there's some pretty
trans girls out there, too. Um but, you
know, I I don't want my future
girlfriend to have a penis. Sorry. Just
something about me. Not not a huge fan
of my future girlfriend having a penis.
Um
>> [laughter]
>> It's so So, pay attention.
Pay attention. There's some passoids out
there.
Um
and so you're just going to have to
swipe. And of course like the one
through 10 scale is going to be
contextual to you. I think I showed you
guys like a map of the way that I think
you should evaluate a person. Like what
it As a matter of fact, I should I'll
pull it up.
Yes. Yes. Um Yes.
>> Where did I put it? And I partially drew
this map because I knew that I was going
to be on the dating market soon, you
know, and and I knew that I was going to
be evaluating my partners
based on this criteria.
>> deleting that message, but just clarify
this public information. Just please
clarify this public information. He
shares that publicly. Excuse me. He must
do. Yeah, he must do he must share that
information publicly.
>> Now, if if I actually had to rate myself
okay
>> Yeah, he must share that publicly. He
hangs out with Destiny.
>> I'm going to say I'm a solid seven and
on a good day I'm an eight for physical,
okay? Financial, I'm a three.
>> [laughter]
>> On a good day, I'M A SIX.
>> OKAY.
>> BUT YEAH, that's how you that's how you
>> that I love and if I figure it out, I
could be an eight or 10 on the
financial. Now, emotional
>> one day. I'm going to make it one day.
I'm a five, maybe a four.
But I'm a self-aware
four or five. And I think self-awareness
does a lot for like emotional stability.
Like if you're a [__] mess, it is
what it is. Like in a in self-awareness
can obviously like increase your
emotional stability bracket, in my
opinion. And then spiritual beauty, I'm
probably it really depends on what
you're into, right? If you like somebody
who's like abrasive and fun and
adventurous and weird and likes to deal
with [__] up [__] and all that kind of
stuff, I could be the most spiritual
beautiful person you ever met. I might
be like an eight out of 10. Like I might
be a nine out of 10 on spiritual beauty.
But if you don't like vulgarity
>> If you don't like looking at the horrors
of life if you don't like looking at
violence, if you don't like looking at
politics, if you don't like looking at
you know, if you don't like
being verbally abrasive, then I'm
probably like a two, you know? It
actually straight up depends. In the
spiritual realm, like your soul, who you
are and what you're about, it actually
really depends on what you're into.
So, what I would say, bud123,
>> What's his strength and charisma? is
having honest evaluation of what and who
you are.
>> Drop in I drop I drop in and waste real
quick.
>> spectrum? Are you six? Are you seven?
Because being short, even if you're
handsome as [__] and you got a rocking
[__] body and a decent face, being
short, a lot of women will not date
attractive short men, which I think is
[__] up. But then you got to go after
short [__] You got to go after I'm
going to use I'm going to be sexist. You
got to go after short [__] or really,
really, really tall [__] okay? I'm
not kidding. Well, like I almost
guarantee you, if you're 5'5 or 5'6,
you're going to end up dating a chick
that's 5'4 or you're going to date a
chick that's 5'11. You know what I'm
saying? Like like the the whole 5'4 to
5'10 range, where they're vain and they
all want like a 6-ft dude, ignore those
[__] And if anybody gives you
[__] [__] about your height, [__]
them. You know, I'm actually [laughter]
just talking to my short kings in
general. Man man look perfect too. Let's
go. Needed Needed this guys. Needed
this.
>> to date an Amazonian [__] goddess
that you're going to have to climb like
a [__] oak tree
or you're going to date a chick who's
your height or shorter. It's just my
prediction. I've seen so many women
dismiss
fit, good-looking guys because of height
that I literally would not even let it
be a part of your calculation.
Finances. If you're well-off, [__]
are going to use you for dinner, okay?
So, just be aware that you might link up
with an attractive woman and you're
going to like [__] fall head over
heels for her. She might be using you
for dinner. So, unless you're getting
like good vibes, where she actually
seems to like you and appreciate you and
laugh at your jokes and you have good
banter, Is that for real? I don't think
that's I don't really buy that, man. I
don't really buy that. I don't you know,
maybe like there are some like, you
know, 18, 19 or that type of [__] I
don't buy that any woman over like 25 is
doing that [__] There's just no shot,
bro. There's just no shot. What I like
what may happen is that there's like
they may need like
that they may if they see a way to they
could be women that get see a way to get
money out of a guy more extensively, you
know? A really self-interested woman
could see a way to get out of a money
out of a guy more extensively and keep
up a relationship because she's able to
get
recurring money. But the idea that for
the dinners, no, I don't buy that. I
don't buy that women are going on
multiple dates with guys they
actually don't want to date at all just
for the just for the date. Just for the
date. I don't not not broadly. Sure,
some women sometimes. Not broadly. I
don't think that's a broad trend. Free
dinners happens in like New York City.
Yeah, I feel like it's like a type of
person that's like, you know, it's a
status thing to always be out and [__]
I don't know. I feel like most people's
experience is not going to include
people like that. I just don't think
that's a thing, really. Sure, you're
witty and all that kind of [__] still
prepare for that chick to be using you
for a free dinner, okay? Just be ready
for that.
Uh emotion
Let's all be sure to take this
relationship advice from someone who is
recently divorced. So, I'm getting
divorced and spent 2 weeks on Tinder.
Here's how you should Here's how you
should run your life. All right, man. No
problem. Okay, no problem, man. All
right. That you with the $20 Caesar. You
do appreciate it. Thank you. Emotional
stability, figure out where you're at on
the [__] map, map it, be self-aware
about it, and then spiritual beauty,
just have some higher pursuit, dude.
Whether it's like work or fitness or a
hobby or community service or
volunteering or whatever, try to max out
your spiritual beauty stat. Because a
lot of women, while they can be very
vain about height, I think that they
will overlook
uh emotional issues and some physical
issues if you are truly a funny,
beautiful, and soulful person. Like,
I've seen all sorts of ugly
[__] have girls that they
should not have based off of like the
sexual marketplace, but it's truly
because they have
>> you're like a drug dealer, like a
beautiful, funny, cool
>> Drug Drug dealer's got a lot get lots of
women. Yeah, that's that's I mean, I'll
check out the Discord or whatever, that
but that's part of my recommendations
right there. Is know who you are, know
what you're looking for. So, let me let
me engage with chat for a little bit.
We're already at 2:20, so I [__] up
the Hassan segment, but
I figured I might as well share with you
guys what's actually going on in my
life. So, and also, you know what? Bro,
that's so funny, man.
Average Average Hassan hate a segment.
Average Hassan hate a segment. Made the
way through Sorry, guys. I've been
derailed by talking about my recent
divorce and two-week experience on
Tinder.
>> [laughter]
>> Wife took the kids. I want some [__]
I you know, you don't have to applaud
me, but I'm going to applaud myself,
okay? I could have crashed the [__] out.
I could have like gotten wasted and not
shown up to stream. I could have started
like recklessly abusing drugs. I could
have [__] freaked the [__] out and
imploded my entire life, and I was like,
"No." You talk all this [__] about like
being responsible and being smart and
trying to handle your [__] as best as
you can, and [__] dealing with life
as it comes to you, and you know, how do
you eat an elephant? One bite at a time.
I always have all this [__] stoic,
goddamn advice for people about how to
live life.
>> [laughter]
>> And so, I was like,
"I could become a drug addict. I could
become a [__] I could become a drug
addict. I could implode my life
financially. I could [__] everything up.
But no, I'm going to [__] take my own
advice and I'm going to ride this [__]
out to the raggedy [__] end and I'm
going to try to handle it like a [__]
man. And I swear to God
partially my desire to handle it as best
I could was because I didn't want to
disappoint y'all. Another motivation was
because I didn't want to disappoint my
kids, you know? I really didn't want to
But my audience first, my chat first. I
didn't want to fall apart, you know? Cuz
what what is falling apart going to do,
you know? How is falling apart going to
make anything better? And so I didn't. I
just didn't fall apart, you know? I
cried a couple of times, but I didn't
fall apart. Jonas says, "I get nothing
on dating apps, any of them. I used to
get hella matches. I think they changed
their algorithms at some point."
Probably, but once again, based off of
it in my mind, it's like a swiping game.
Effectively, you swipe a thousand
[__] profiles saying yes and saying
no in order to get like
half a dozen [__] DMs, dozen DMs. And
then out of a dozen DMs, only one of
them is going to turn into a mediocre
coffee date. You know what I'm saying?
Like obviously I was only in the game
for 2 weeks, but like that seemed like a
sane ratio to me. It's literally like
thousand swipes for 10 DMs for one IRL
date. And I'm not I'm not knocking the
person that I did an IRL date with. We
actually had a really good date. We
actually had a really good couple of
dates, but you know, that that was the
ratio was thousand swipes, 10 DMs, one
date.
And then I could see too, especially if
you get that one date and it's very
mediocre, how that could be super
[__] disappointing because you put so
much goddamn effort
>> Yeah, I need to know the yellow flags,
red flags. So I Guys, it just gets
better and better. Pisco's reviewing the
denim's filing. Dude, it just keeps get
You're going to get tired of winning.
You're going to get ti- killer video.
Conor divorce, PSGO denim's filing.
You're going to get tired of winning,
guys. You're going to get tired of
winning. I sympathize deeply with the
[__] bros out there [__] grinding
it out. Oh, advice. I got some more
advice, okay? So, uh bud123, especially
since you're a fitness guy, there's a
app called Lunge, l u n g e. And there's
also
an app you should just Google like
fitness dating apps. And on Lunge, um
the basically like the quality So, there
there were way less people because la-
way less people were on the dating apps,
but the quality of people was way
higher. Where effectively it's girls who
were in running clubs, it's girl- I
swear to god, 80% of the cute chicks
were going to Crunch Fitness. So,
wherever you're going to the gym, cancel
your gym membership and go to Crunch
Fitness, okay? But, um
it was
Pilates princesses, it was running club
girls, it was um I'm trying to think of
what else. It was a few CrossFit girls,
for sure, and a lot of them were very
attractive. And then, of course, there
were some larger girls who were also
trying to find like a fitness buddy. And
so, I actually do recommend um Lunge
because I got a few matches on there,
and I would say the quality
was substantially higher. I didn't um
there was one person So, I got a few
matches on there, and there was one
person that I actually could have taken
out on a date, but the distance was
super long, so we didn't end up linking
up. But, you know, uh I I don't I don't
know what personality
compatibility we would have had, but,
you know, that Let's just say there
would have been some physical
compatibility. Let's just put it that
way.
I can make some meanest [__] butter
chicken. Nice. Learn to make a good beef
burgundy. You can make it in huge
portions and it's very nutritious. Okay.
Forget the stove and oven. Grills cook
meat and potatoes flat. Wait, what is
this? Flat top cooks all veggies. Okay.
I mean, I'm cooking fine. I'm doing
great. Dude, I have pooped. Sorry for
saying that word to you, but I have done
so much uh
my my fiber [__] has been on point. My
my greens, my veggies have been on
[__] point. Tinder in Miami is a
trash heap. That's true, but it's also
[__] Miami, dude. Like you should be
able to find something in Miami. No
offense. I'm a three especially when
grassroots isn't around.
>> [laughter]
>> How are you a four emotionally
stability-wise? I just got a lot of
[__] trauma, dude. Just just law
enforcement Hey guys, don't joke. Don't
even joke.
>> to be honest. I just got a lot of
[__] trauma. I I work through my
trauma. I deal with my trauma well, but
I have a lot of trauma. I would call
myself maybe an eight or nine naked,
definitely a nine, and as a partner I'm
pretty dope, so I give myself a seven.
Okay. I mean, if that's an honest
evaluation of who you are, then
just get good at rizzing. I mean, yeah,
sure.
>> Dude, how long does he go for in this
topic for?
>> to a lady who is 5'5" and I'm 5'6". It's
great. See?
See? I raise my hand as a short king. I
chase tall women. My wife is 6'3". There
you go. There you go. Funnily enough,
the biggest handicap to being a trans
girl on Tinder is being post-op and not
having a penis. Are you serious?
I'm not Val. I don't know if you're
saying that for you or if you're saying
that in general,
but that is funny to me because I don't
think that I would date a trans girl
who, you know, had a penis, but I'm also
not surprised that you said that.
>> But would you wait, would you date one
without? Cuz I feel like, you know, the
type of person that's willing to a tool,
it's usually because of like the the
fetishization of the idea of being sort
of both, right? That's usually I think
what's going on there. I don't
It makes a lot of sense that they would
actually
prefer pre-op. I I just don't I just
struggle to think that Connor would be
willing to a tool. I don't think Connor
would date a post-op trans woman cuz
that [__] not good either, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> There's probably men who want that. That
That That's It simultaneously surprising
and not.
Most women who say this [__] will only
look at your face.
>> Cuz it's in the videos, bro. Cuz it's in
the videos. Or just wear off
relationships in service to your nation
or God. Yeah, okay. Yeah, let your
entire genetic lineage die. Hundreds of
thousands of years of humans figured out
how to [__] have kids, but just let
your entire [__] genetic lineage die.
Good job, Wicked Radiation. Yeah, just
give in to the pessimism. Just never try
to find anybody.
>> Wait, when we had this debate and you
were anti-cock I I [__] I don't I don't
remember that, dude.
That's sarcasm, by the way. Please go
find somebody who wants to have your
kids. Or maybe that was DK. One of us
was anti-cock.
Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh and Miami is a very vain place,
Jonah. So I I'm not trying to I'm not
trying to like hate on Miami too much,
but basically like cuz I I think I And
what was what's that classic forever
line? The classic forever line.
From our group chat.
>> guy who ever did anything near
appropriate after he got divorced was
Aaron Bushnell. Thank you for the $5.
That's Aaron's comment. Counterpoints
told me he sets his filters to only
include girls who are cute and funny.
I'd quote what he means by that. Thank
you for the $5. You are appreciated.
Thank you.
Um
yeah, when for when Forever said So
you'll be begging for poorly packed
roast beef baguettes when you see what's
coming next. Cyborg [__] from hell.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> Craziest [__] one of the craziest
messages I've ever read, bro. So good.
>> [laughter]
>> Bro, that was so good, man. Busted out
my [__] distance to like 200 miles at
one point and I was getting Miami
people. Uh but I think that uh Miami
people, obviously there's a lot of rich
people and there's a lot of boats. So
even like sixes and sevens are getting
on boats in Miami. So it's just like a
super vain place where money is going to
be uh you know, that that you're going
to be spending 50 bucks on your first
date at minimum in Miami. And that's
going to be considered a cheap date, you
know, that's tough.
>> [sighs]
>> Azia says, uh that was great. Thanks for
sharing. Yeah, yeah. I figured I might
as well rip the band-aid off. What are
the things that I'm going to try to do?
And by the way, that was like super
uncomfortable. I I did not I have not
wanted to tell you guys that [__] at
all. But you know, if I'm going to
constantly quote Tyrion Lannister, where
Tyrion Lannister is like, you know, wear
what you are like armor, that way it can
never be used against you. If I'm
constantly going to be quoting that,
then obviously I need to be honest about
what's going on in my life right now. So
AK Matias I kind of just probably a few
out there looking for visas. Dude,
straight up straight up. Maybe I'm an
idiot, I don't know. So I'm obviously
sticking with my girlfriend because
she's amazing. But Dude. there's a part
of me that if you all had like money or
even if you didn't have money, but
there's like a a dating for like
Ukrainian women, Oh my god. [__]
green card. I would [__] I I'm not
kidding. The only reason why I wouldn't
get a mail-order Eastern European bride
is because I wouldn't want my family to
judge me.
And I wouldn't want to get divorced
again and lose half of my [__] again.
>> [laughter]
>> So So you got to be careful. But I swear
to God, if my family wasn't around to
judge me, and if Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. I'm
having like a [__] brain blast and
maybe I was [__] Uh guys, I spoke
to
an IRL friend recently and they told me
uh
they have another friend that I
remembered being sort of mutual friend
groups and that we spoke to. They told
me they have a friend that's also a
YouTuber. Um and but but they told me
this person went to Thailand for several
years and uh now lives back in the UK
with a Ukrainian girlfriend. Does that
mean he's doing Is he probably doing
some like, you know, some like chain
passport bro [__] You think that's
That's crazy. Dude, how did I not clock
that? How did I not clock that? I would
use I would usually clock something like
that and ask more questions if someone
said something like that to me. That's
so [__] annoying. I'm going to have
to I'm going to have to ask more. Um
if my family wasn't around to judge me,
and if I had a pre-nup, I might straight
up like marry like an Eastern European
chick. Because like, dude, what are the
chances that she's ever met anybody nice
in their entire [__] life? You know?
But like Eastern European Okay.
>> men have a
huge reputation for being [__]
[__] and being like traditional
conservatives where if the women don't
follow what they say, they'll beat the
[__] out of you. So you can't be a
[__] Being nice and being a put You're
not going to hold on to your Ukrainian
mail-order broad if uh broad bride if
you're
>> What's the appropriate amount to beat
your Ukrainian mail-order bride so she
stays with you? Great questions to
ponder on, eh? Yes. Let's Let's Let's
consider this. Let's consider this. The
most divorced conversation of all time
they're calling it. If you're a [__]
but being a [__] and being abusive are
two different things. So, if you could
find a Eastern European girl who wanted
a [__] green card and she wanted to
like marry a truly nice man and she was
beautiful and you were nice to her, you
know, that there's a chance that as long
as you weren't a [__] but you were
still kind, you could have a good
relationship. So,
yeah. They're powerlifters and they'll
princess carry you if you're lucky. I
mean, yeah, muscle mamas. Yeah, got them
muscle mamas.
>> Dude, please. I don't want to hear some
40-year-old talking about [__] muscle
mamas. Dude, please. Cut it out. Take
Take any language like that out of your
vocabulary immediately. Yeah, there were
some. There were some, you know? Lot of
Pilates princesses, lot of running club
girls.
>> Dude, yeah, yeah. Wait, wait, wait.
Can't Can't do this [__] bro. I can't
do this [__] Can't do this [__] dude.
Sad that there's no muscly girls in
here. Well, I mean, yeah, but you know,
sure, I like to joke around and talk
about how all strong women all the time,
but that's not the only girls I like. I
like big girls, pretty kitty girls,
really witty girls, singing diddy girls.
I like the lanky girls with the nice
thighs. I like a good chest, no matter
what size. I like the belly folds. I
like the six-pack, really tall queens
and the short kings. From the mild girl
>> It's not too bad. It's not too bad. But
there were a few muscle mommies, too.
[__] me, man. Some won't mess with you
if you have less than 100k karma on
Reddit. Dude, dude, if a chick won't
date you because of your [__] Reddit
score, that's crazy. That I [__] that.
Okay. Carter's finally eating his
salads. I know, produce, dude. But the
problem with produce is you got to go
pick it up every three or four days. You
know what I'm saying? So, you got to You
got to keep up with it, but I've been
keeping up with my produce and it's been
great. But 123 says, "I'm in Bozeman in
between semesters so the dating pool may
not be great." Yeah, yeah, yeah. That
That's going to be tough, obviously, but
then also I would literally So So think
about this. Sorry that I'm giving
[__] dating advice even though I
literally just got out of a 15-year
relationship, dated for 2 weeks, and
then started dating somebody else that I
knew from real life. So I'm probably not
the best for this digital media
landscape and I'm also not [__]
enough.
>> Cringe, but the response was
disproportionate. Um
it depends what you mean. Obviously any
you know, I'm I'm sure that guy got like
dogs and [__] like that. Any of that
that is [__] up. But in terms of like
the intensity of emotion, I I No, I
think the response is perfectly
proportionate. And there were probably
some actions I'm sure people took that
were way too far that were way that were
[__] up. However, no, actually I think
being totally enraged sent into a
near-violent spiral by that video is
actually a totally proportionate
response. to give you [__] advice. Go to
Destiny for [__] advice. But what I was
going to say is expand your meet-up
distance for what you would be willing
to drive, okay? And what I mean by that
is So for instance, like a vehicle on a
highway goes 60 miles an hour, and would
you be willing for the right person,
okay, the right person, would you be
willing to drive 3 hours to hang out for
the weekend with the right person? If
any of you are curious about Connor
immediately tickets to the underground
Slav auction that was in the end of
taken it so obviously because he didn't
do anything wrong and he doesn't need
time to introspect at all. Thank you for
the $20 Jimbo. Thank you. And the answer
to me for me was like, "Yes." Like Like
I would drive, you know, long distance
is the wrong distance. You don't want to
sign up for a long-distance relationship
unless it's absolutely necessary. But
let's say that Bozeman
>> Unlike Connor, Jimbo has going to leave
his wife and kids on his own terms to
beat Kabila. is 2 hours away from like,
I don't know, [__] What What What's
the place at Steve's from? What's What's
the Nebraska city that he's from? What
Whenever somebody talks about Nebraska,
they always talk about his city. Like,
isn't Isn't Mark the capital, and isn't
the other city that Steve's from?
Uh
big cities in Nebraska. I know that
sounds like a [__] Omaha. Omaha. So,
Omaha and Lincoln are pretty small
compared to Florida, but Omaha has half
a million people, Lincoln has 300,000,
Bellevue has 65,000,
Grand Island has 50,000, Kearney has
35,000, Fremont has 30,000, Norfolk has
26,000, Hastings has 25, Papillion
Papillon is 25,000, and Columbus is 24.
So, I don't know what your next biggest
city is, but I would literally open up
your like, if you're on Tinder or Hinge
or whatever the [__] you're using, I
would literally open up the distance to
incorporate your next biggest city.
Because, you know, for the right chick,
you would drive out, you know? I would
drive two If If If the options were date
somebody that I [__] hate who's 10
minutes away, but I do it for
convenience, versus on Fridays driving 3
hours to a town or maybe Saturday for
the first date, but Saturday driving 3
hours to a town that's 3 hours away, but
then I get to go on a date with somebody
that I actually have chemistry with, and
then we can hang out all day, and if
they have an apartment or a house, we
can hang out at their apartment or the
house, and then as you get into a
relationship, you can spend the entire
weekend together. I would rather spend
the weekend and drive 6 hours a week in
order to spend the weekend with somebody
I truly liked rather than, you know,
driving 10 minutes to somebody like,
yeah, maybe they're hot enough to hook
up with, but they totally [__] suck
as a person. I I would rather drive 3
hours than drive 10 minutes. So, Expand
your Expand your [__] zone to the
next biggest city is definitely a
recommendation from me. Connor 2026
post-op only. Oh, I think I scrolled up
a little bit on accident. My Yeah, I
don't know, man. [__] that. [__] that.
That's like terrible advice. I feel any
Like this guy It feels like this guy
Yeah, here's my Here's my read right
now. He's like rushed into some
relationship and he wasn't looking to
wait around. You know, if you
blitz like that, sure, maybe that's the
way to do it. Most people, I think, use
dating apps over extended period of time
and it's more of like a, you know,
scattered approach. It's like you're
just looking to be able to quickly go,
you know, be able to go on a date with
someone and then, you know, see if
you're interested in them or not. You
don't want to have like entire [__]
days set out so you can get into a
relationship as quickly as possible.
That's not how most people operate, I
don't think.
Sorry for scrolling up on you. Christian
Layer says, "Appreciate the personal
yap. This means we're not finishing the
kilo content, right?" Yeah, but I'm
going to do it eventually. I need to do
it as a segment. Fell Runner says,
"Monday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday on
counter or on Valor and then Counter
Points Politics we're on
We're on tomorrow, true." Can't do that
till your kids are in college. I don't
know what that's in reference to. You
could have become a gooner like Destiny.
I know. I know, but I didn't want to. I
didn't want to. You know why? Because if
I dated a [__] 22-year-old and she
was just getting out of college and she
didn't know her [__] ass from her
elbow, and then like, yeah, sure, maybe
we had some physical fun, but I felt
like I was taken advantage from like a a
psychological or emotional or maturity
perspective, I think I could have fun
temporarily, but I do not think that I
would be having fun long term. Now, if
you had like a 25-year-old chick who was
smart as [__] who was like a [__]
law student, who could just like see you
see through your [__] I think it's
I think it's different to date a middle
20 to late 20-year-old who is smart as a
[__] whip, ambitious as [__] and can
see through your [__]
uh versus dating like a 22-year-old who
effectively like all you have is
physical compatibility, but she actually
has like a lot of growing up to do.
I think there's a big difference between
those dynamics, and I think those
dynamics are important. I would be
interested
>> He's 38. You know, obviously I'm I'm
with my current girl, and I don't plan
on going anywhere. But, if I was to date
anybody in their 20s ever for the rest
of my life, they would need to be in
their mid to late 20s. They would need
to have their [__] together. They would
need to be be ambitious, and they would
need to be able to see through [__]
You know what I'm saying? They would
basically need to have an old soul. So.
>> [laughter]
>> Christian Wire says, "Here's how Tom
uses divorce as a clapback." I mean,
they can.
They can.
>> They never do that.
>> Like the They would never do that.
They would never do that. With the
liberals and the progressives, they can
just say, "Oh, you virtue signaled about
your family." And it's like, I'm still
going to virtue signal about my family.
I was with somebody for 15 [__]
years, and I still love my kids.
>> Oh, they're I'm not even using this to
make any point or simp you and Connor at
all. It's just funny that he shares all
this. It's funny to laugh at. It's funny
Yeah, it's like Schadenfreude. It's just
like, you know, it's just funny. And
he's sha- he's sharing gory details that
are very amusing.
I'm still going to [__] yap about my
family. And then, I'm moving from one
stable relationship, hopefully,
into another stable relationship. So,
we'll see. They can use it. They can use
it if they want. Dating market is almost
half as bad as a job market. I'm sorry,
buddy. I'm sorry. Yeah, check out
I'm serious. Check out Lunch, and then I
think there's something called like Fit
IRL or something like that. Just
literally Google Google like fitness
dating apps and check out like the top
five and then download the top two.
This is why you describe people as
sending me back to the days of Starcraft
UMS maps, high school wars, or whatever.
I don't know the reference, but cool.
Also, I'm in both Oh, Bozeman. That's
what That's what sent me down the down
the Nebraska Google search. There's a
lot of dudes who want to get [__] in
the ass by someone with tits. I'm
unsurprised by that. Jeb Kush says, "I'm
gay. I donate a sperm, so if I die, my
bloodline will says, "There you go."
Matter of fact, who was the guy who was
doom doom scrolling? Wicked radiation?
Dude, if you're not like a total Oh my
god, why do I have to hear this [__]
retard's name? I'm going to blow my [__]
smooth off, bro. I am calling for
literally everyone to ban Wicked
Radiation from their communities. Just
blanket across the board. Has he done
anything to us or violated or anything?
No. But holy [__] is this guy [__]
annoying and [__] And nothing is
that he says is ever of any value. It's
never funny. It just makes me find so
[__] annoyed. [__] physical
mutant, then go down to the sperm bank,
man.
Oh, I don't love it.
I genuinely do not [__] with this guy.
>> not a total [__] freak mutant.
Yo, thank you Malcolm for the raid.
Thank you. Welcome in. Welcome in
Malcolm raiders. Tyrion is not wrong.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. He's not wrong even if it's
hard. I agree. I agree.
>> very autistic. He's schizophrenic. He's
actually schizophrenic. He said many
times he's schizophrenic. That's why he
everything he says is so [__]
[__] dude. So none of it makes any
sense. It's out of the way, but we are a
better community for it, O 7. Okay. Azia
says, "Hold on. I don't want kids ever.
Why are we hating on me?" Cuz I'm a
pro-natalist. Sorry. Sorry, Azia. I'm a
pro-natalist. I [__] I think Here's
Dude, here's the only person in
literally like I swear in four or five
years, he's the only person I have
ignored on Discord. He's the only person
who I've made it so I just don't see
their messages. I just I just I
literally I never check them. I like
never check them. Only today when he was
arguing with us something that I check
them. I only today only one time today
and it literally I haven't seen a
message from like 2 weeks. But he got me
to that point. He got me to that point
in which I literally I just cannot I
just could not look at the messages.
That was it doesn't say anything
derisive about me. Not even trying to
annoy me. He's just got He's just so
[__] irritating. I think having kids
is like the coolest [__] thing you
can do. I really really really do. I
love I love my Not only do I love my
kids, I think having kids is one of the
coolest things I've ever done. Excuse
me. What if you've been banned from
Reddit for using bad words? Do I get a
prize? Hopefully. Chia seed pudding is
amazing if you want to hit fiber goals
without eating like a grazing animal.
Cool. Thanks for the recommendation.
Although I I can't remember the last
time I had chia seeds. I'm I'm imagining
like red seeds that kind of like pop in
your mouth and they're kind of sweet. So
maybe like chia seeds and yogurt.
>> [snorts]
>> Omaha like the beach? Yes. Which came
first, the beach or the city? I think
the city. I don't know about Chad the
builder, bro.
>> tribe. True. There's a lot of chicks
that live in the building I work at that
are crushing on me, but like I work
Dude, [__] that Jonah. No no no Jonah,
I'm sorry. I hate to [__] up your [__]
Dude, every single person I dated was
somebody that I met through work or
school.
So first first girlfriend who I'm dating
right now, school. Second girlfriend,
school. Third girlfriend, school.
>> Voice crack. Uh fourth girlfriend,
military. Then fifth girlfriend, school.
Sixth girlfriend, school and work. You
have to [__] where you eat, bro. If
there's a good looking girl who is
actually crushing on you and she's like
cool, interesting, smart, ambitious,
etc. You got to ask her out, man. You
got to ask her out. Like I I I hate to
say that this because that actually puts
some pressure on you. But, dude, you are
infinitely more likely to have a
rewarding relationship with a co-worker
who already likes you than you are
starting from scratch on a [__]
dating website, dude. You absolutely
like unless you're their boss, you 100%
need to [__] where you eat. [__] that.
You need you need to
if there's a girl who gives you [__]
googly eyes like so for instance, back
when I worked at Nordstrom,
I still remember this girl's name, too.
There was a girl named Suzy Vella, okay?
She she worked at the Hot Topic and she
used to come in
every week basically for like 3 months
in order to buy shoes from me because
she was a Vince Camuto addict.
And like we would talk about shoes, we
would talk about fashion, we would talk
about life, we would talk about this,
talk about that. The only reason why I
didn't ask her out was because I had a
girlfriend. But, I 100% would have asked
out Suzy Vella if I wasn't dating
someone.
And then
what's the other thing? There was a girl
who used to work at So, Nordstrom had a
coffee bar and there was there was a
girl there who was like younger than me.
I was probably mid late 20s. I was
probably mid 20s. And she was like 19 or
20. And she would kind of always like
hand me my food with like the extra, you
know, 3 seconds of eye contact. And
dude, if I wasn't if I didn't have a
girlfriend, I 100% would have asked that
chick out. Are you [__] kidding me?
[__] that, dude. You abs- if there is a
girl that you like at your work who is
cute and you guys are socially
compatible, you have to act her ask her
out. Do not waste that opportunity.
>> So, this isn't too crazy. It just
depends, man. It just depends.
>> orbiters or sweepers until you start
picking fights with them online. You got
to branch out from all the other Hasan
haters. Sure. Nothing ages you more than
a crowd of 20-somethings. true. Early
20s girl def isn't in the mood. Walt,
dude, if you're in your mid to late 20s
or early 30s, a young 20s girl is in the
cards. You know why? Because you're
young as [__] Because you're dumb as
[__] No offense. I'm the same guy that
I was when I was [__] 25, but I have
so much more experience that makes me
more [__] salty, dude. You you have
to understand like even if you're 25 or
even if you're 29, you're still young,
man. You are going to do so much growing
in the next decade.
>> So true. You have to do that.
>> You're 25 to 29, you're still young.
That's facts, Skallagrim. Thank you.
Thank you for saying it. Thank you
someone was brave enough.
Just be cringe, man. Ask her out. She
says, "Ew." Okay, keep it [__]
moving. You ask another girl out. She
says, "No, thank you." Okay, keep it
[__] moving. You ask the third girl
out. She goes, "Oh, I always kind of had
a crush on you. That's so funny. Haha.
But I have a boyfriend." Okay, who gives
a [__] You cringe a little bit. You
keep it moving. Ask the fourth girl.
"Hey, you want to go out sometime?" She
goes, "Yeah, actually that would be
great."
Sick. Do it. See if they have a
personality behind their aesthetic.
Dude, do not worry about dating in your
late 20s and early 30s and thinking that
[__] like 22 is a deal breaker. It's
not a deal breaker. The reason why it's
a deal breaker for me is cuz I'm almost
[__] 40 with kids. You know what I'm
saying? And I'm not even saying no to
like the physical part of it. I'm just
saying like I would pay a price
afterwards and I'm not interested in
paying the price. So, Christian Myers
says you don't need to get another job.
No.
>> [laughter]
>> Not as long as Grass or Tench come back
at some point.
I'm kidding and I'm not, okay? So, where
um
I have I don't need to get another job.
I just need to actually do my job here.
So, for instance, I need to go finish my
expanse breakdown tonight
and it is 2:44, so I got to roll in a
second. I need to go finish my expanse
breakdown tonight and then I need to get
three Counter-Points Politics VODs out.
Then,
I need to actually create the Rhino
channel and I need to grind it out. With
income, obviously Grassroots being like
30% of income and then of course like
when somebody donates a whole bunch,
that kind of motivates everybody else to
donate.
You know, that obviously that's going to
hurt for the two or three weeks that or
month that he's in rehab. But, the truth
is that like no, like like all of my
bills are
>> I saw blessing for my what? and if I
have a couple of rough months, it is
what it is.
So, no, it's not a big deal. And maybe
this will spur me to be more aggressive
to do the stuff that I say I need to do,
like being aggressive about Rhino, like
streaming more and doing community
nights and all that kind of [__] So,
no, I I do I do not need a new job
anytime soon. So, I I
I wish Grassroots the utmost and the
best in his recovery. And if some of you
[__] who are graduating with
master's degrees, if you get your six or
seven figure jobs, throw in a little bit
of cash my way, I'm not going to
complain about it, but no, we're we're
doing okay.
So. So, his biggest oil is going to
rehab. That guy will not be donating
when he gets out. Okay.
Not the way you're saying it. Dude, the
voice cracks are crazy, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> But, what I actually would do is let
let's say that you lived in Omaha, okay?
And I actually did Google this
back when I was back when I was dating
my Orlando house social worker or
whatever because I wanted to date a
nurse. I'm dating a teacher, which is
great, so I'm not complaining at all,
but I wanted to date a nurse. And I
literally Googled where do the nurses
drink after shift in Orlando?" And
there's a specific bar.
So, if I hadn't bumped into my
girlfriend, and if the social worker and
I had broken up, I was literally going
to go to the bar where the nurses drink
after work.
And I was just going to hang out there
and see if, you know, I vibed with
somebody. And then same thing with the
teachers. If you're like, "Damn, I want
to date a teacher, not a student, a
teacher."
I would literally Google, "Where do the
professors from X college go out to
drink? Where do the teachers from this
school go out to drink?" Because
sometimes there'll be like a forum post
or a Facebook post or something like
that where it's like, "You know, we have
half off education industry night on
Thursdays. Special shout out to Eagles
Nest High School for dropping by." And
there'll be like a picture of like, you
know, a dozen
teachers
from the local school who are taking
advantage of the industry night on
Thursday. Go on [__] industry night,
right? Maybe you'll bump into somebody
who's cute and you say, "Hey, what do
you do?" And they're like, "Oh, I'm a
teacher." And it's like, "Damn, I really
wanted to meet you. That's cool. What do
you teach?"
>> [laughter]
>> Like, listen. Listen, like I said, I'm
I'm off the market and I do not plan on
being on the market, but this entire
scenario has like, you know, it's jogged
my memory on how to meet people. So,
like strong, strong, strong recommend
that if you want to date a teacher or
date a nurse, find out where they have
like industry nights for those
industries that are close to the place
that you want to find somebody who works
there, and then go there on the industry
night. And even even if you don't meet
your wife or girlfriend, you might meet
somebody who is cool and is your friend
and introduces you to your wife or
girlfriend. You know what I'm saying? Or
boyfriend, whatever you're into. Uh,
they're more like clients, but I feel
you. Okay, yeah. Well, don't If you're
like, what are you? Like a physical
therapist or something? I understand
asking out a physical therapist, that
can get dicey because I think they have
like prohibitions against asking out
clients cuz it's like unethical. Uh, but
if you [__] vibe with somebody,
[__] risk it for the biscuit, bro.
Worst case scenario, you get [__]
shitcanned.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh, Destiny Peterson musical time. God
damn it, do I have to?
Isn't it like 5 minutes long? You've
donated for it twice, so I feel like I
have to.
>> bro. That's crazy. The the right amount
of story. So, let's go. Are you looking
[laughter] for that stability or you
dating somebody because you want to hit
and quit? That's huge. [laughter]
That's [__] huge. Uh, [__] love
whimsy. It's so true. So true. [__]
do love whimsy. Did you ever watch the
Destiny Peterson music
music video and then you donated, so I
have to do it now.
Nurses are just graduated strippers. Who
gives a [__] Sometimes that's a vibe.
The final evolution from stripper to
nurse is porn star if doctor doesn't
work out. Okay, problem. You really are
live. I thought YouTube was lying to me.
Nope. Nope, we kept going. So, Jen
Winkler, I don't know if you caught it,
but uh, basically, unfortunately, Mrs.
Points and I split. So, Mrs. Points has
been downgraded
from Mrs. Points to Mama Points. And uh,
I am dating a teacher. Don't date a
teacher unless you want to nap daily.
Who the [__] doesn't want to nap? Hey,
man. Pull your old man, by the way.
>> love naps. You [__] me? I try to
stay away from picking up women at bars,
never ends well, always some kind of
[__] or drama. Uh,
Real Series for 100 Argentinian pesos
says, "Hello, Mr. Points, we're with the
FBI. Did you Google Google and
subsequently Eagle Points High School
where they drank yesterday?"
>> [laughter]
>> I'm looking for teachers, okay?
Teachers, not uh,
not students, to be clear. Do not Do not
use any of the advice that I just gave
you to try to date a high school student
or I mean, you could date a college
student, who gives a [__] But, ideally,
you know, you should go for the
professors.
So.